come one come all to the magical kingdom
of arendelle
it's got sentient snow monsters magic
trolls and a talking snowman who loves
her warm hugs and long walks on the
beach it's ruled by Elsa a nice wealdian
queen with the heart of gold but don't
let her kindness fool you
she's the ice queen after all and she's
one bad day away from turning arendelle
into a permanent ski resort Elsa Anna
Kristoff and a few new faces are coming
to a theater near you but who are these
newcomers really are they allies enemies
or something in between keep watching to
find out frozen too is slated to hit the
big screen on November 22nd 2019 and
although the sequels release date is
quickly approaching we're nowhere near
close to finding out who the franchise's
newest characters will be we know for a
fact that a couple of new characters
will be joining the production this is
confirmed by Kristen Bell who plays Anna
during an interview with cinema blend
she stated that there are a couple of
new characters that everyone will fall
in love with but who are these newbies
and what are their names so far we know
the actors Evan Rachel Wood and sterling
K Brown will be voicing the newest
additions of the frozen teen but who
will they be playing exactly as of yet
we haven't seen too many new faces flash
across the screen that is with the
exception of a brown haired girl and a
blond-haired boy these mysterious
figures make a short appearance in the
first frozen two trailer but that's all
we needed to see to come up with some
very convincing theories now that a
brand new frozen - trailer has come out
we have a bit more context to work with
so let's explore the possibilities the
past is not what it see
there's a chance that Elsa and Ana's
parents come back to the big screen
despite having suffered a shipwreck in
the first film however they won't be
coming back from the grave or at least
we hope they won't
on the contrary we might be shown a
glimpse of the past where we'll see
Prince Agner and princess eyes dunno
long before they ever got married and
had children if you look closely you'll
see that the mystery girl looks a lot
like Queen I do now and the same can be
said about the boy and King Agner we
also know that these strangers are most
likely gallivanting through the
enchanted lands
grand pabbie warns the gang but why
would a young I dunno and a teenage acne
RB traveling through the enchanted lands
and why is Agner being thrown into the
air like a plastic bag on a windy
afternoon there's another theory that
seems pretty legitimate and it's one
that links these mystery characters to
onon Christoph's future there's no
denying that the mystery girl and anna
look a lot alike we mean they're
basically the same person and the young
boy with blond hair also bears a
striking resemblance to Kristoff if you
take a closer look at the girl you'll
notice that she's kind of wearing the
same type of outfit as Kristoff she's
wearing the ice Harvester colors and
everything the boy on the other hand
seems to be wearing a teal overcoat
which is often Ana's color of choice so
could these two characters bianna and
Christoph's future kids and if so how
are they going to work that storyline
into the movie seems a little
complicated if you ask us which is why
we prefer the next theory we have to in
the first frozen film a young Elsa
mistakenly struck Anna in the head with
ice so their father ran to the library
and took out a book that led the royal
family straight to the trolls in this
book we see a picture of a blond-haired
warrior lying down on the stone bed who
we believed to be grandpappy is standing
over him and expelling the ice from his
head we have reason to believe that this
unknown relative was struck by someone
who also harnessed ice powers but since
Elsa wasn't born yet who could this
mystery person be so what if the blonde
boy we see in the first trailer is one
in the same with the man
storybook could the boy and the girl
have been journeying across the
enchanted lands to the same place Elsa
and the gang are headed towards and
frozen to if these two teens reached
their destination
someone with ice powers might have
struck the blond-haired boy in the head
with ice causing him to seek the help of
the trolls perhaps this could be the
reason that Elsa has the wintery powers
because while her distant relative was
struck by ice which somehow altered his
DNA if this is the case it's possible
that the two strangers from the trailer
will appear during the flashback moment
however this brings us nowhere close to
finding out who the two new characters
will be another possible explanation is
that the people we see in the trailer
have nothing to do with Evan Rachel Wood
and sterling K Browns mysterious
characters it's very possible that
Disney chose to omit them from the
trailer and throw us off their scent
many frozen fans are convinced that Elsa
will meet her love interest sometime in
the sequel and they think that she'll
belong to the LGBTQ community so could
Evan Rachel would scare achter be else's
future girlfriend or are we grasping at
straws here at first we thought that
Evan Rachel Wood character would be
responsible for the pink fire but now
we're not so sure it's possible that our
heroes make new allies during their time
in the enchanted lands these two new
characters could help Elsa Anna Kristoff
and the gang find exactly what or who
they're looking for
if you guys think that Evan Rachel Wood
character will turn out to be else's
girlfriend leave a blue heart emoji in
the comment section and while you're at
it let us know if you have any theories
of your own thanks for watching the
things give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button we'll see you next time
[Music]